the children's dairy association was
born about three years ago within the osa
baugiano agritourism to give
young people and young people the opportunity to
experience multifunctionality
in agriculture
one year from 5,000 to
10,000 children come to bausano divided into and schools that
come  during the week families
who come at the weekend kids
who come during the summer
is multi-functionality on the farm
certainly leads to an increase in
jobs because in addition to working with
animals
the one between from the garden in
transformation in direct sales
in catering  in hospitality
if my farm were only
productive
two people would be enough but being
the multifunctional farm I
work for 10 people
despite the economic crisis my
company has seen an increase in revenue
thanks to the diversification of
activities and above all thanks to
direct sales
my company is very small
but for this reason it
can be replicated
to see the children and young people who
approach the countryside and who work
the land despite the effort and the
dirt is what makes me get up every
morning from bed